it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen go ahead do it you got time or
visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert
Elizabeth Warner joins us right now
let's get right to us so we have
something that can help your lawn Stay
Green during the summer that's right
because you know we live in Suburbia and
we have lawn Envy don't we that's true
Grass Is Always Greener well I'm going
to show you exactly how to do that make
a lush yard for a cost efficient way and
an easy way all you're going to need is
a hose in about 15 minutes this is
Sunday all of these products are created
to fertilize the yard your plants your
trees your vegetables and even knock out
your weeds no pesticides no toxic that's
key exactly so I'm out in my garden and
when I'm out in my garden you can see my
dog running around with me as I'm
actually spraying this wait that's it
that's me that's my house and let me
show you look at my garden growing it is
amazing to see how everything just turns
green and grows so quickly it's simple
easy to use simple easy to use and
amazing so this is an actual
configuration just for the CBS family
normally you have to subscribe to get
Sunday materials so the set of three is
68 but they have products starting at
cbsdeals.com at just 17 so 22 off
special CBS deal yes okay so what do we
got this is hungry spurtles all right I
would love for you okay to open up that
peanut butter and just see how easy this
is to use these have a curved design
which gets helps us get into our pans a
lot easier helps us get into jars even
little Caper jars smooth that right out
and you'll notice me at home when I'm
cooking with these I like to cook up a
whole storm so I'm making my spaghetti
squash at home well how do you get it
out you use this nice long handle it
goes right in and I can even scoop out
the meatballs from my gravy using the
spurtle that's got the slots on it so
that's great for straining for using as
a whisk you can separate your eggs with
it so all of these fertiles replace
every other utensil in the kitchen and
they're sturdy buy one get one so you're
getting a set of four but you're getting
two sets of four for just 19.99 that's a
Super Deal yes all right so you know
when you're in your room and it's sunny
and you see little things floating
around in the air yeah you breathe those
in but you don't have to are those bad
those are not they're pollutants we
don't want to breed the dust in right so
the air purifiers these are amazing when
we turn these on they're different
settings so we can go sort of low or
high they're rechargeable portable and
these are going to clean the air around
us so they're going to take out 99 of
bacteria and germs pollutants think of
pet dander think of allergens think of
pollen all of those things and guess
what else odor so with me I'm in the
kitchen I'm chopping onions I can't
stand it I put this next to it pulls the
odor out and this has something that you
can attach and then put in your cup
holder in your car so you know when the
boys get in after practice it's a little
smelly the kids were running in and out
of the house yes the house was a little
funky because of football practice and
we were sneezing I changed the filters
it wasn't the filters
this is what you need over a hundred
dollars off a hundred over oh sorry
69.99 it's 58 off I was jumping over
here okay we'll jump over to buy 179.
okay yes so this is the calming heat
sauna wrap now you've been in a sauna
what does it do for you
after you go to practice right you get
to sweat out all those toxins it helps
your muscles this helps calm the mind
and the body a spa experience can be
really expensive this is
179.99 and you're getting a spa
experience every single day at home it's
like a warm hug and I'm telling you I
put the kids to bed I lay down I put
mine on the floor you can have it on the
bed water resistant so when you're
sweating you don't have to worry it's
not going to go onto your bed or onto
the floor Elizabeth Warner you are the
best we appreciate you now we're partner
with all these questions
cbsdeals.com I'm not getting in that bed
with them because I'll get in trouble